[Music]
it is spoken in my Village of an evil
that lives in the mountains above
evil an evil that appears as a man when
it wants to hide its true nature and
that night he feeds on the blood of the
innocent the elders they made bargains
safety of our people
you were given to this man it is not the
man an animal no it is not some mindless
animal either do not make that mistake
we call him Dracula and you you believe
that
he brought you on board
why
[Music]
feed
he is here Mr Clements
the thing that wears the skin of a man
[Music]
in the night it rings our blood that he
is on this ship
You'll Never Leave It
the Demeter on Charter from Romania to
London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival in London
let me show you the this
here we don't come with like this to
give the use clear
[Applause]
something ripped about the animals
on the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it drinks our blood he's just
here
we call him Dracula
he's coming
did you see the size of that bloody
thing
[Music]
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]
thank you